hello everyone and welcome to Game four
of the semi-final match between England
and magnus carlsen as you well as you
all know by now
game 1 ended in a draw then dink won
Game one and then Carlson retaliated in
game 3 so the match is tight and whoever
wins this game wins the match or if this
game is a draw then we go into the to
blitz mini matches which occur after the
the for rapid games have been played so
without further ado let's check it out
as this is also a pretty wild one
so being opens with d4 and here Magnus
replies with d5 we have C 4 and now C 6
Magnus goes for the Slav defense and
joins everyone else who also plays the
Slav here we have Knight to f3 Knight to
f6 Knight to c3 and now e 6 the semi
Slav and III now being ready to develop
the LightSquared bishop we have Knight B
to d7 and Bishop to e2 now with Bishop
to d6 and both players Castle Dean
castles cross and castles and b3 now
preparing to finca to the dark square
Bishop ending does the same for his
light square bishop so b6 gosh up the
beat you we have Bishop to b7 and here a
4 and that there is one game in the
database for a 6 plate but here cross
and goes for the immediate a5 and it is
as I move 10 that we have a completely
new game so ding now continues with
Bishop to d3 which is the bishop over to
d3 why not develop the Bishop to d3
right away probably he's waiting to see
where where where where black will
develop with his light square bishop but
other than that I don't really have a
good explanation or maybe he didn't want
to go Bishop d3 right away to allow D
captures on c4 before he plays b3 I'm
sure there's a there's a good point to
it but as I've never studied it I can't
help you there so rook the c8 and the
Queen to eat you now connecting the
rooks developing the Queen and here the
immediate c5 by Magnus which gives up
the control of the b v square and the
ding immediately capitalizes on that he
goes at night the b5 goes after the
bishop here and Bishop to b8 nicely
controlling the knight and the cross and
Lex is two bishops here slicing all the
way over to the Kings side if the
position opens up should be
for him and now tonight's the five as
well and here there are a lot of
characters possible you can capture here
you can capture here you can capture
here so of course you have to calculate
all of it but Carlson says that it's not
yet time to capture anything he first
goes Queen to e7 develops the Queen
connects the rooks and now Dean just
reinforces the knight on e5 with f4 so
now we do some trades D captures and C
sorry that's a that's not a D D captures
in C for we have D cap B captures and C
for ending out night Stewie for just
getting the night also to to an
excellent square so now both of them I
have their nights in the center of the
board and if you want to kick it away
from there since you don't have an F
point you would have to give up your
life for a bishop which of course you
are doing a never saw rook 8 d1 biding
adjust the continuing development and
rook C to d8 by Magnus countering that
rook on the D file and Bishop to a 3 now
not allowing captures as well there's
just a queen on e7 so here Carlson goes
for Knight captures on e5 we have F
captures on e5 and now f5 strengthening
his knight but also asking or you may be
interested in each character's on f6
help us all which of course you're not
as you do not want a free free up the
bishop pair from hell a Carson is hiding
back there so look back the b1 if the
knight moves the basics pawn could
become a target a but crossing goes for
Queen to g5 instead now it's it's a bit
dangerous you have to you have to
constantly be worried about a move like
f4
so first rook the b2 biding we have
looked to f7 now preparing to double up
on the F file and now quinta a1 biding
we have rook F 2d 7w government the D
file instead now that there is nothing
here you might be interested in
capturing and before so rook the e2
biding and now adding more more defense
to the e3 pawn and now h6 by Magnus not
yet interested in capturing so first h6
improving the position and now bishop
the back to be to adding another
defender to the d4 pawn and here bishop
the c6 and what players are very long
time but magna
much much lower on time we have Bush of
the c2 are just you know wait waiting to
see what the other guy will do in kink
the h8 another improving of the position
hopefully not like like in that again
with King to h7 and here we have worked
f3 biding so what is things idea here
putting the rook in front of the bishop
like this it looks very dangerous
especially if Magnus goes for something
like Knight to c3 which opens up an
attack on the rook and attack on the
other rook also there's this bishop and
queen action going on here towards the
g2 square so what was things plan if
this happens well it's hard to say as
Magnus did not go for Knight to c3
Magnus went for Queen to g6 instead and
dink went for rook to h3 this is why why
he made the rook lift but the cousin
just repeats Queen to g5 and ding
repeats rook to f3 we have Knight to c3
now now Magnus goes for it and ding
immediately as soon as Carson played
this opens up a double attack here and
here dingos 4 D 5 and now Carson is ok
I'm gonna definitely grab the rook with
check and then we'll see what happens
so knife capture Sonny to with check
Queen captures and now it's it's a good
question what do you do here obviously
Carson is up the exchange but dink has a
massive center here and his bishops and
two rooks aren't doing anything for the
moment so he you do need to do something
about that so what you can do is you can
capture here you can but if you capture
here then you lose control of the f5
pawn which would be very good for white
you could move the bishop you could
capture on b5 capturing on b5 doesn't
seem like a bad option captures captures
and rook to f8 and then you just
continue playing the game but then White
has a lot of option you can play d6
which pretty much gets this Bishop out
of the game for the rest of the game and
the dings position is is definitely ok
being the exchange down another option
is Queen to h5 but this is a disgusting
engine line not not for us humans to
find however if you play something like
that then you give up the bishop but
then you have work to do to which will
be incredibly strong for black and after
Queen to f1 you're gonna capture here
and it's just bad for white the rook is
coming here and that's just game over
however Carlsen went for Bishop
to be seven instead he he saved his
bishop and now he's saying okay if you
capture or something I can still play
rook to d2 it's not a problem but dingos
for rook to g3 instead we have Queen to
h4 and now Magnus was already below one
minute on the clock and dink had a well
over three minutes so here there are a
lot of moves to consider you could
consider some repetition with rook to h3
you could consider efore the free up
your light your own light square bishop
there are a lot of things to consider
but ding just played b6 and he didn't
want to spend too much time here and
okay it's definitely a good move not
allowing this bishop to enter the game
pretty much ever
so Bishop the e4 by Magnus now
countering White's light square bishop
and bishop the d1 ding doesn't want the
trade as Carlson is extremely long time
so Carson goes back Bishop the c6 and
now rook the h3 again forcing the Queen
to move Queen g5 ending repeats rook to
g3 Queen h4 rook the h3 and Queen to g5
and ding here spend so much time trying
to figure out a way to continue the game
that he even came lower on time than
Magnus here both of them were not on now
like below 30 seconds and here everyone
thought now ok ding repeats it's it's a
draw we go into the Blitz in mini
matches however dink went Knight to c3
instead and he said I'm not gonna waste
this position I want to win this I want
to move my queen and get the Knights to
eat you to f4 and then put some pressure
on e6 and g6 and so on while your rooks
and the ship's aren't really doing all
that much I do have to keep an eye on
the g2 pawn not to get made it but you
know other than that I'm doing okay so
Magnus now has to figure out a plan on
how to play against this plan with 30
seconds on the clock he goes for rook to
f8 now has some ideas of maybe playing
f4 but the dingos Queen to f2 he
prepares knight Knight to e2 to f4 and
now if F 4 then you can also just block
with E 4 and then the light square
bishop is also out of the game so
Carlsen can't really afford that he goes
back with Queen to d8 and he figures out
a way how to get back into the game and
free up all of his pieces dingos nights
that e 2 and now Magnus first King to h7
you don't want to allow any jumps on g6
with the trick so Knight to f4 and now
Magnus goes for Bishop Capra's on d6 he
gives up a bishop to free up all of his
other pieces and here you should go for
characters characters and then just
continue the game d6 pawn is now nicely
protected however ding went for Knight
captures on e6 instead he goes for an
attack against the Queen and the rook
which means that he wins his exchange
back but that that's pretty much all
there is to it we have Queen to d8 for
Magnus and now Knight captures with
check but now you don't get the bishop
as a bishopric actress on f8 and here
Queen captures an f5 binding this comes
with check and here Magnus just kicks
the Queen back with g6 and now we have
this position where ding is up a pawn
but it's just anyone's game both players
are extremely low on time and anything
can happen and here you look at this
position we almost reach the position
from the thumbnail here white needs to
play Queen the c2 or Queen to be one at
keep the game going however ding played
Queen to f1 as it does look like it
makes more sense but but it doesn't so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the only move that wins the
game for Magnus while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting the double attack and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's rook to d2 with an attack on the
bishop and also on the G to pawn and
that's just game you cannot defend
against both you have to play Bishop
Bishop to f3 and then you just well
either either capture on f3 or you just
grab the bishop on b2 and well you wait
for for whites to capture here it's it's
not a problem but yeah Magnus did not go
for Google rook to d2 instead he went
for Bishop to g7 he doesn't want to
allow any any Queen to f7 check once
everything opens up like we already
mentioned yeah so it's just a much safer
Square and now Bishop the c2 biding
again allowing this idea and this time
Magnus doesn't miss it here instead of
this you have to you have to play
something just a move move those bishops
out of there like Bishop to f3 or
something counter that light square
bishop however being repeated with the
bishop to c2 and now
Magnus doesn't miss it now Magnus goes
for Luke to d2 and it's again a double
attack here but now it's you you even
have two bishops here to choose from so
whatever you play here you will lose one
of the bishops you will be down a piece
and of course I lose the game so after
that move 45 it was in this position
that England resigned the game and
Magnus Carlsen wins the semi-finals
so we have the the final that pretty
much everyone was expecting Magnus
Carlsen versus Hikaru Nakamura in the
finals of the Magnus Invitational which
we are going to enjoy tomorrow on a nice
Sunday
nothing much to be done here and it was
a really really crazy game so many
blunders so many missed opportunities
and it's like it's like Magnus is really
really nervous about playing ding and
the ding is super nervous about playing
Magnus whenever he has a good position
but yeah that's that's basically the way
chess has always been so nothing funny
going on there oh yeah once again that's
the game and the coverage of the match
Magnus versus dink I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Simon heat one
inch Intel virus James in low Daniel
Silverberg and anagen goalie for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous video so
your think of for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the Magnus invitational until it
finishes
ah so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day
and do join us in early chess team
battle arena that starts a fairly soon
now after I upload this video the links
are in the description below thank you
all and I will see you soon